Speaker 1: Let's hear from some people in
the audience. Why don't we? We've done well
with it the last few weeks. We take calls
via discord at David Pakman dotcom slash
discord. Let's start today with a corner from
Atlanta, Georgia. Koner, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. Yes, hey, so I've
been watching your show now for about a year,
I found a funny enough first time I actually
saw you was on Jesse Lee Peterson show, OK? And
I've been kind of doing some soul searching.
I'm 19. I voted for the first time
back in November. And I've been doing some
soul searching in regards to politics. I don't
I really because because I would usually say
that I was a I guess, an independent, a centrist,
whatever you would want to label someone who
doesn't really associate themselves with a
political party or say, I've never called myself a
liberal, I've never called myself a conservative,
I think because there because I guess if I
could maybe give you an example, like I'm not
really big into, like the online left politics,
like with the council culture and and things
like that. And I'm not I'm not when it comes
to like, I guess Republicans or conservatives,
I, I'm not really I don't really believe in like
the so-called embracing tradition, quote unquote.
Speaker 1: So kind. What's and what's
an example of like a cancelation
that happened that you disagree with.
Speaker 2: I guess I wasn't a big fan of
when Gina Carano got fired from the
Mandalorian for her comments. I think
that there were people who probably did much
worse things that still have careers like, say,
James Gunn winning 10 years about a decade
ago when he made all those nasty tweets and
he was fired, then he got rehired. And I just
that's one thing I say I disagree with. I was
not at all not a fan of Trump at all.
Speaker 1: OK,
so, Conor, did you did you have a question
today? Just because we've got a bunch of people
who want to get on, I think I have a sense now
of your politics, but did you have a question?
Speaker 2: Sure. OK, OK, I do have a question
about Palestine and Israel. Why do you I don't
know if you think this, but at least I got
this impression from someone I know, someone
who watches your show. He mentioned how you maybe
believe that it should be under the control of two
belief systems or ideologies rather than one.
Speaker 1: What should be under the control?
Speaker 2: The Palestinian Israel issue
Speaker 1: going, I believe, in a two state
solution that maybe that's what your friend meant.
Speaker 2: Yes, yes, yes, that's what I meant.
Yeah. Why do you believe that as a as
as opposed to a one state solution?
Speaker 1: I think there is absolutely
no chance that a one state solution has
even the possibility of bringing anybody
even to the table. As difficult as some
people say it would be to negotiate a two state
solution that would be acceptable to both sides,
there will never even be a negotiation about
a one state solution. So I see it merely as
something that gets it's guaranteed to get us
nowhere as opposed to maybe gets us nowhere.
Speaker 2: OK, I see, I see. All right,
well, I appreciate it, David, thank you.
Speaker 1: All right, Connor, thank
you. There's Connor from Atlanta.